today for our daily cancellation i will
be canceling drivers
all drivers in america except for me i'm
the only driver who is not cancelled
because i'm the only good one
all other drivers are canceled you are
all no longer allowed on the roadways
so i expect smooth sailing for myself on
the highways from here on out
as the only person in the country who
knows how to drive now
i have long suspected that i am the only
good driver i've known it from before i
even had a license my dad
took me out to give me driving lessons
when i was 16. by the end of the first
drive
i was giving him the lessons that's not
entirely true i guess i i think after my
first lesson he was yelling at me that
if i don't learn to stop at stop signs
i'm going to hit someone and kill them
and he's not going to bail me out of
jail um but anyway
the point is very quickly over time i
became the only good driver
now it's well known that every man
believes that he is the only good driver
my dad believed it about himself and his
dad about himself
and you if you're a man listening
probably thinking about yourself but
it's not you
i assure you it is me which is an honor
and a point of pride but also a burden
because i have to constantly deal with
the awful driving of everybody else
this has especially been the case over
the last two weeks when i've done a
significant amount of long long-distance
driving
uh hither and yan here you know there
and back and everything else and
i'll be continuing that by the way um
i'll be uh i'm driving up to grove city
for my speech after the show today
grove city college on thursday i'll be
speaking for yaf there so
make sure to make sure you you come and
tune in to that
but my recent dr my recent driving is
only affirmed and confirmed that
everyone is bad at driving except for me
now
let's go through a list of the types of
drivers who are especially canceled
you'll certainly find yourself on this
list somewhere there are the obvious
villains you know the drivers who drive
too slow in the passing lane or
pass in the right lane the drivers who
don't use their turn signals the drivers
who turn their turn signals on far too
early or far too late drivers who drive
under the speed limit
on one lane roads and let the cars pile
up behind them
going on like that for miles while the
people in the cars trailing behind
stew with rage and begin engaging in
violent and unspeakable fantasies
drivers who take too long to start
driving again when the light turns green
and also drivers who start honking
immediately when the light turns green
and don't even give you a damn second to
move your foot from the brake to the gas
pedal
drivers who who speed like psychopaths
in residential neighborhoods
drivers who use their high beams when
there are other cars directly in front
of them
or driving past them in the opposite
lane drivers who slam
on their brakes when they see a cop and
a speed trap nearly causing a 15 car
pileup and also calling attention to the
fact that they were just speeding
okay the cops aren't dumb they're going
to see that dozens of other examples
but here are the three main terrorists
of the roadways that deserve
specific and special condemnation
number one drivers who don't know how to
merge
properly i've always said that merging
should be on the driver's exam maybe it
is now i don't know
when i went through it it wasn't instead
you practice making three-point turns
and doing a couple other things
and then the final test the final boss
of the driver's exam when i was
doing it was a parallel parking
parallel parking a skill that as
expected i excel at but
that most people can go their whole
lives avoiding if they really want to
merging on the other hand you can't
avoid if you do it wrong as many people
do you'll get someone killed
now you'll notice an emerging situation
as you are merging onto the highway
there is most of the time a sign that
says yield
and very often there is a thing called a
merge lane
this is this is an area for you to drive
on as you merge
but most people experience some kind of
selective blindness and act as though
the yield and merge lane don't exist
what they'll do is in rarer cases just
dart right into traffic charging in
as if the other cars on the highway are
made of pixie dust so there's no reason
no need to worry about
collisions more commonly though drivers
will treat the yield like a stop sign
and the merge lane like it will collapse
into a sinkhole if they drive on it too
far
so they'll come to a screeching halt in
the merge lane and wait for an
opening in traffic and then enter the
highway going about 14 miles an hour
oftentimes causing whole busloads of
orphans and puppies to veer around them
and go careening off the highway and
over a cliff it happens all the time
now it's like it's like they they take
that entrance ramp
and as soon as they see the highway they
panic
and they just stop still and they start
shouting what do i do
what do i do help help what do i do
you drive is what you do okay what
you're supposed to do is continue
driving along the merge lane speeding up
to match the speed of traffic
yielding to oncoming traffic and
entering the highway as soon as space
opens up and allows it
it's very simple you go with the speed
of traffic number two parking lots
many drivers will cause unneeded
congestion and chaos in our nation's
parking lots by insisting on driving
around until they find a spot that's as
close as possible to the entrance of
whatever walmart they're trying to
access um these are the kinds of people
who
when you're you know when you're in a
spot and you're getting back to your
spot with your groceries they'll be
sitting there with their blinker on
impatiently waiting for you to pull away
putting undue pressure on you to unload
your groceries and buckle your kids up
and leave meanwhile there's a spot
literally 14 feet away that's
open and available they would rather
wait for 14 minutes
in order to save themselves the 14 feet
this is the incorrect strategy the
correct thing to do is
is when you're in a parking lot pull
into the first
open spot you see no matter how far it
is from the building
when i when we go to football games in
the city for example as a family back
when that was still legal
i'll just take the first spot i find as
soon as we get into the city even if
it's 27 blocks from the stadium by the
time we walk there it's halfway through
the third quarter
but you know what i am not contributing
to parking lot congestion
unlike the rest of you heathens three
finally
this is a big one stop signs most people
know i hope that at a four-way stop
whatever car arrives first has the
right-of-way
if two cars arrive at the same time then
the car to the right has the
right-of-way these are the rules
the problem happens when there's
confusion or uncertainty about who
arrived first
and at this point in most four-way stop
situations everyone is frozen in panic
and fear nobody knows what to do
someone in one of the cars must lead
must take charge of the situation now me
being the only good driver i of course
always assume this leadership role
i say to the other drivers do not fear
do not be afraid
for i am with you i will show you the
way and at this point i will
magnanimously wave the other driver on
i'll just like this with generosity and
kindness in my eyes i will say go
go my child be free go but then what
always happens
the other driver will start waving to me
and they'll say oh no i couldn't i
couldn't accept this gift
you go you go my liege please i beg of
you so i say okay i accept your terms
and i start to go but then right at the
moment that the other right at that
moment when i'm going the other car says
never mind i think i want to go and they
start going and then i stop and say
okay then you go and they say no no
seriously you go never mind and i say
fine i'm going
and right as i start to drive they say
actually i think i kind of like to go
and they start driving and this game of
stop and start goes on sometimes for
hours
days this could all be avoided if you
would just
go from the first moment i wave you on
this is the rule of good driving if you
get waved on
just go just go you got
the wave go go you idiot i don't care if
i'm waving you into a volcano
you get the wave you go never defy the
wave
the very order and stability of our
society depends on the power of the wave
when you're driving so go and don't
forget to give the thank you wave in
return you ungrateful bastard
most people struggle with most of these
points everyone but me struggles with at
least some of them
you might argue that i clearly do
struggle with immense amounts of road
rage and am not psychologically fit to
be driving the streets or indeed to be
in human society at all
that may or may not be the case but this
isn't about me
stop changing the subject this is about
you
and you as a driver are canceled
so if you're driving right now while
you're listening to this just pull over
get out of your car
leave the car there walk home that's
your only choice
all right um good glad we could
establish all that
that was very loud when i did that okay
uh
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening godspeed
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends